okay should we get started yeah
fantastic
it's lovely lovely to see you or thanks
so much for coming just in case anyone
in the front has trouble seeing because
the obviously I'll be standing in front
of this screen you feel free to shuffle
round as we go my name is Nick
I'm from data lust I'm here to talk to
you about building passes in c-sharp
like the kinds of phases that you write
for little little languages probably
from big languages but we're not really
just gonna look at the how I want to
look at this from the very lowest level
building blocks so that when you walk
out of here you might feel like there's
no magic involved in parsing languages
and that's something that you might
consider even using in your own real
world applications things that other
developers have to work on and maintain
but this story begins story begins ten
years ago I think my cold winter
afternoon I was hunched over my desk in
Microsoft Building 41 and an email
popped up into my inbox my boss is
really interested in this IRC stuff and
he'd been doing some work in that area
would you mind coming down to the cafe
to answer a few questions so I'm sure
enough okay I'll come I'll come down
have a chat quickly check the org chart
before I head down the stairs and ah
this boss is Eric Meyer and with no
preparation at all I'm about to try and
explain what I think are the benefits of
dependency injection to dr. Meyer who
obviously needs no introduction so then
sometime later when Eric Meyer was
explaining functional composition he
quipped that dependency injection is
just for programmers who don't know
maths and I had to stop and really look
at it myself then but when I came back
to preparing this talk well I know I've
got an hour slot I probably need to
allow 10 minutes at the end for
questions or at least for running over
and then I have around 30 30 meaty
slides to get through so how long do I
have
each slide I can't really do that in my
head so maybe there's some truth in this
but I know a few things about computers
and so is there a way that we could
simply get the computer to answer this
for us and so I've got one hour
and we've got 10 minutes at the end and
there 30 slides so I'll have to divide
that I know that much and we need some
friends okay
so we'll have 1 minute and 40 seconds
for every slide that's plenty of time
right and if in that 10 minutes sorry in
10 minutes if I need 30 seconds per
question say how many questions could we
could we get through we get through 20 I
really do that in my head as well but
you can see that in some domains little
little languages are a great great way
to express problems and there there's
some times faster P really user
interface to the other kinds of tools
that we normally have in our tool kit
like forms and buttons and and things
there's a whole class of interfaces that
I really awful when they're implemented
as gooeys and you can imagine especially
things like we recent issue trackers
really bring that to the fore where
little languages are fantastic and the
first the first kind of realization of
that for me was when I was introduced to
databases and then at that point I think
using ball and paradox writing a query
meant kind of dragging around boxes that
represented tables joining them up with
lines representing foreign keys and
relationships and then kind of iterating
until probably the wrong results that
came out but at least something that I
could convince myself was what I needed
once you learn sequel obviously you see
that there's a there's a far superior
way if you have to work with databases a
lot to interact with them through this
little language just a force now a very
big language and we know this
intuitively as programmers but we're
very hesitant to introduce languages
into our own applications I think partly
because when we first introduced to that
field it's a very large complex
interesting field and all that detail
kind of obscures the a few small truths
that you need to be able to handle
languages once I learnt what we're going
to talk about today in this talk I
started to see opportunities everywhere
to use languages to improve api's and
turn improve the way that the products I
worked on we used I'm some of the ones
that I can talk about that
a kind of public is I worked on an
octopus deploy in the early versions you
were seeing the octopus folks downstairs
Paul I were able to take the templating
language and octopus deploy and instead
of just substituting variables into your
configuration files and your and other
things at deployment time we introduced
loops and control floater so that you
can conditionally create your
configuration files or even generate
them from the variables that describe
that deployment of course languages
don't just appear in interfaces via for
end-users they're also for developers
and by using a little language to
capture structured log events sera log
which I worked on was able to to make a
really low barrier to entry for
structured logging unit and we now have
that throughout and log and done that
framework as well and then day to day I
work on this thing called seek which is
a sequel over Jason log log store or
event store that's used for Diagnostics
and log analysis and you don't just sort
of wake up one morning and say hey I'm
gonna write a sequel over Jason the
Vince store and then I better go and
learn how to how to deal with languages
I think the the key to this is that once
you realize that these are just
programming techniques that you can that
you can apply those opportunities all
present themselves to you and the other
way ah so what's the problem then why
don't we do this
if you look at the expression in this in
this example there's every chance that
you can see the problem at a glance I
think we've we're all familiar with how
expressions a representative trees you
have nodes that represent the values and
then you have higher level nodes that
connect them up with operators like the
minus and divide that we've got in this
example once once the data is
represented as a tree then all the usual
tools that we're familiar with like
recursion and and switch statements and
the rest of it can be brought to bear on
calculating results so who's whose work
was recursion in the past
yeah and an trees dealt with trees yeah
but there's there's a lot of experience
in those in those kinds of technologies
and you can see that evaluating an
expression that's represented as a tree
where say here expression is the the
root node in the class hierarchy and
we've got duration value and numeric
value that evaluate to simple values and
then we've got binary expression which
recursively evaluates its left and right
sides before dispatching an operator now
you'd imagine that sweating away over
switch statements and recursion for an
afternoon most of us would be able to
come up with the value of an expression
given the tree form so we can we can
deal with trees and we can deal with
recursion so what what is the problem
and it's this that we need to take the
sequence of characters and and bunch it
up in just the right way so that it
represents the the the correct tree
structure that the the expression
describes and you might say well I know
regular expressions I can just aura can
string split that and regular
expressions can only produce lists the
limitation of regular expressions is
they have no way to describe nesting and
so if you are working with regular
expressions you can only really create
flat data out of your input to create
data structures that are tree shaped you
need to use a parsing technique this is
probably all you need to know about
Chomsky's Grandma hierarchy in one slide
for the practical programmer so what's a
parser a parser is just a function that
takes a string as input and returns some
value as an output that's kind of a joke
really because I mean obviously that
tells us very much it tells us
everything nothing about passes to write
useful parses and the ones that we'll
examine we need to be a bit more
prescriptive about how they receive
input and how they return results so the
two structs they'll introduce called
input and result play this role like
input is like a cursor into the source
text that we're gonna pass and it's
immutable so
the only way to advance input is to call
next jar and then you get a result that
represents the either the successfully
retrieved character or maybe a carry
scenario information like in this case
probably we would have reached the end
of the string and so we might get
nothing back once we do get a character
back then the remainder on the result
will give us the rest of the input that
we're yet to pass and using these two
types we can work through the input
character by character in a fairly
obvious way
so to parse the number 123 we look at
the first character and if it's one of
it's a digit then we take that digit
value and store it away and if we look
and find another digit then we can just
multiply whatever we have by ten and add
that new value on so we multiply one by
one by ten and we get ten and then we
had on the two and we continue that
process through the rest of the string
and this is the mechanics of input and
result so you can see in the first line
we call input dot next char and if the
character is not a digit then we'll
return the empty result but otherwise we
start that looping that we were talking
about a moment ago multiplying by ten
shifting stuff up and eventually we
we've consumed as many digits as we can
find and we returned the whole remainder
along with that value and this is not
pretty code this is certainly not
intended to be exciting it's only really
here on a slide just to prove that there
isn't any magic at this level we'll keep
looking at more levels and and just off
I guess any chance of there being magic
hidden in there too because pauses are
just functions we can use regular
programming techniques to write pauses
so to get a parser that can recognize
any particular character we can use this
function sha 65,000 pauses for the price
of one and it will just look at the
character that's next in the stream and
if it matches what we're we're looking
for then it will succeed with that value
in otherwise it won't given that we can
parse natural numbers and we can look
for a dot in this case then it's not too
hard to imagine combining these two
paths decimal numbers that have got a
whole part and a decimal point in a
fraction of
and you can see that we can do that in a
fairly straightforward and mechanical
way here to create ourselves a double
parser we just apply a natural which we
wrote a moment ago we apply a dot and to
make sure that we've got a decimal point
in the middle and if we've successfully
gone all the way through there then you
can imagine that we might have written
the fraction parser to deal with the
leading zeros in the and the rest of the
input and if all of that succeeds and we
get to the bottom then we can add the
whole part and the fractional part and
we've got our double we haven't really
written a lot of positive there and
we've got a lot of code and it's very
tedious code that was probably
error-prone and I can't imagine that a
positon for a full-scale language would
be very much fun to work with if we took
this kind of direct approach so I stare
that all down I start again to improve
this situation we can observe that
pauses of functions and c-sharp has got
some good features for abstracting over
functions to use them we really have to
describe what the signature of a person
looks like and there's our a delegate
called positive T there that takes an
input and returns a result once we have
that signature defined we can write
other more tricky functions like many
and many isn't a parser it will actually
take the deposit for an item here we've
got say a positive called smiley which
would take some ASCII characters that
describe a smiley and returned the
Unicode equivalent now we can pass that
through to many and many will just try
to apply that parser as many times as it
can on the input stream until it can't
succeed anymore and the results of
applying that it will return in a list
so many works on any positive that
conforms to that positive T signature to
make everything conform to that
signature though we have to make some
modifications to passes like char and
now instead of char being a positive
that directly works on the input char is
a function that returns passes and we
give it the character that we want to
match in it will give us a positive back
that that will only match that character
so we have two more ingredients that we
need in order to be able to simplify
this kind of sequencing of parses then
is the the signature of then is
admittedly a bit more complex than there
then it would be pleasant to look at at
first sight but but then takes the
positive that's going to be applied
first and then if it can successfully
apply that parser it will call the
function with the with its result to get
the second parser to apply and once
they're both and once they've both been
I once they're both being called it will
return the result of applying that
second parser return is a little
building block that simply succeeds with
a value and consumes no input a little
bit mysterious but now if we go back to
this example of sequencing are three
small passes into the into the larger
one that can return doubles of house
doubles you see that we've got this
declarative way of sequencing then we
can hit we can say a double is natural
and then we take the whole pit part and
we apply a char to pass the dot and if
we've successfully passed the dot then
we call fraction and return the whole
amount profit plus the fraction and I
can live with this because there
probably isn't much of a simpler way to
describe how three passes would be
applied though in sequence like that so
many and and then and return are just
not the only games in town once you
start thinking about ways that you can
write functions to manipulate parsers
you can do all kinds of tricky things
with them and these these functions that
combine passes are called
positive carbon aiders and the technique
is quite old but it was popularized that
surprisingly not surprisingly for this
talk I guess in them paper by Graham
Hutton and Eric Meyer in 1996 and so
there are implementations of this
concept in quite a lot of programming
languages and it also just so happens
that if we have a couple of specially
crafted signatures for functions like
where and select and select many we end
up with being able to use the link
syntax in c-sharp to elegantly and with
that all right would drift
go in sequence those three pauses that
way you see this is the same positive
written again but with a sprinkling of
some kind of magic I guess now the good
news is that this is a little bit of a
bait-and-switch because we looked at the
low-level building blocks but you don't
need to go and reemployment of this
there are several libraries for.net that
implement powers at Combinator's the one
that we'll look at in a bit more detail
is called super power
I wrote it particularly because I needed
end-user quality error messages out of
the query files of for C there are other
there are there examples that will also
have a quick review of if we have time
towards the end of this talk you can
find super on get up and we do fit on
the screen great so looking at super
power and it's Combinator library it's
got a few differences from the simple
types that we just introduced but the
the power of T type and super power that
will first look at it's called text
parser a super power has a couple of
different options for how to write
passes and text passes the first of them
and it corresponds exactly to input and
result that we were just looking at so
yeah expression language for computing
these little time calculations if we
want to deal with the hour and minute
suffixes to these duration values then
we can create a positive ándale those
and we'll look at this one called
magnitude now we if you think about how
those values are actually structured one
H is really 1 multiplied by 1 hour and
10 M is 10 multiplied by 1 minute and so
that's why this positive written as a
timespan it gives us the magnitude that
we can have that we can apply in a
multiplication to get the full value
it's really the the parser itself is
structured like a giant switch statement
I left it deliberately a bit verbose and
ugly because I mean it is just code so
we could refactor this and have a more
elegant kind of a mapping from these
suffixes to the timescale values Ric
pulling out the carpet now but I wanted
you to see that the the thing laid out
and it's it's kind of full detail and so
we proceed through the input and we try
and we try and match D and if we
successfully find the character D and a
character dot equal to is just char is
that there's a dessert library of these
kinds of pauses in superpower and so
they've got a little bit more of a boast
names so that you can kind of find them
in the classes that declare them now but
if we if we match the character D then
we'll return one day and then we could
work through hours and minutes seconds
and milliseconds you see there's a bit
of an ambiguity when it comes to pausing
minutes or milliseconds and if we tried
the minutes first because it's a prefix
of milliseconds we would succeed right
we would find an M and then we were done
and then we returned that and later on
when we came to try to process the rest
of the input there would be this s
sitting there so we don't want that all
will actually run the these branches
sequentially so to fix this problem we
just put the MS option first and if we
if we can't successfully match the whole
MS then we'll fall back and we might try
and match just an M and for performance
reasons and also to improve error
reporting the library we want to do this
automatically and you have to actually
use try in order to declare that you
want to backtrack if you if you succeed
with a partial match or if you fail with
partial match I should say so there's
the whole thing now once we once we have
the magnitude paths that we can combine
it with a couple of other library passes
like we have numeric decimal double
another very strange name but once you
get used to the scheme this is a
positive that will pass decimal syntax
and return that the value as a dotnet
double so there is just numeric decimal
for pausing the the text that contains a
decimal number and there's also a
decimal decimal and everything's is
really hard at the same still so if we
if we managed to pass the decimal part
then we can use magnitude to powers the
little suffix and once we've got those
values we can multiply them out to get
the duration representatives at times
and unfortunately because superpower
uses structs and it's delegate
signatures there's no there's no
covariance and so there's a bit of a
caste in there because we want to work
with passes over expressions we don't
want to kind of let all of the concrete
implementation types leak all their way
up to how we know any of this works at
all and this is the this is the next
great thing about passes just being
coded they're actually they're trivially
easy to test because the test deposit
which is just a function then you simply
call the function and see whether a
return to the result you're expecting
and so test paws are is just a wrapper
here that kind of cuts a bit of slight
bit of noise out of the slide but we can
feed in 150 H and and see that that
gives us 150 hours just like we could
take the magnitude parser and feed in an
H and see that it gives us one hour and
the puzzles we gonna write are a bit
fractal and that they're kind of the
same at all levels by just being
functions that return values so the unit
tests the test these little tiny
chromatic elements like durations and
numbers are really called in exactly the
same way as the higher level ones that
come that are going to pass whole
expressions so all most of the projects
that I've worked on that have used some
kind of text parsing they're enjoy -
they're a joy to test and modify because
your test suite becomes a really big
long list of inputs really big long list
of their expected outputs and you can
you can write data-driven tests they
exercise a whole lot of different code
paths without very much effort so when
you when you do go back to real life
outside of the wonder of MDC and
consider adding some languages into your
apps if you know if the maintenance
question is raised I think you could
probably safely say that houses are a
lot nicer to maintain than most of the
code that we always deal with like
controllers and even worse web forms
those kinds of joys we've handled I
think I think you have a fairly clear
idea of how we can handle the numeric
values in our expressions and how we can
deal with those the duration values now
looking at the next little element that
of ours is going
handle and these very modular it's a
kind of a modular approach that you take
you can kind of build those poses up
from very small elements we just want to
deal with passing out operators this
time and unlike the very ugly you're a
magnitude passer we've actually done a
little bit of refactoring refactoring
here and we've got this op helper
function that will just generate passes
for us that match your character every
time an item from that enum you see plus
will give us an ADD etc and this is this
is one of the other great things across
because writing a parser as a as a bunch
of c-sharp code gives you all of these
great code organization and refactoring
abilities that you just wouldn't get if
you were using some kind of language
workbench because of course you can't
declare yourself functions like up to
simplify things and now we're into the
very worst of the code dump slides and
this one describes how we produce the
expression tree I guess it's a bit
tricky but there's some logic to it and
that if you look at the top that the
pauses at the top they're kind of the
tight grammatical units that were
passing in this case the language that
we pass is made up of literals which are
either durations or numbers you see try
in there because durations start with
numbers this is one of the strengths and
weaknesses i guess of using Combinator
based parsing you have to be aware of
some of those ambiguities but you get
all of the usual programming techniques
techniques to resolve them factor is a
historically kind of inherited name for
this paz' it's called factor because
it's going to be the left or right
operand of a multiplication or a
division and because of the way that
operator precent precedence works and
binding then on the left hand side or
the right hand side of one of these will
always have a parenthesized expression
because if it's going to be say in
addition on the left will have two
parenthesize it before it's going to be
an operand of multiplication or it would
just be the the very low-level literal
values
term is pretty similar it's going to be
left to right hand side of an addition
or a subtraction and it uses a helper
function called pass chain which goes
and applies well it's a way of creating
operator precedence passes without
getting stuck in things like left
recursion which are problems with this
technique and right up the top we've got
expression which adds the addition or
subtraction operators in you can see
that you've you that you've got the the
operator and then the the operand and
the binary expression dot create will
construct your tree node but I know what
you're thinking right now right I've
just told you to go and draw the rest of
the owl yeah this is the other little
secret and if you put on x-ray goggles
right you're the language that you're
setting out to pars in whatever your
domain of interest is it's gonna share a
lot with just just about a million other
languages of different kinds you see
whether or not the the operator operands
of a plus B are columns in the sequel
query or elements in a JSON document the
a plus B part of that syntax is the same
it's what you do it's how the model
works afterwards that um that is really
unique to your language unless you're
doing something really crazy and in
which case I could probably kind of help
you but once you realize this you see
the C with this sort of extra x-ray
vision that you can that libraries like
super power come with all kinds of
examples there are expression parses out
there that that showed this kind of
operator precedence structure if you
were going to have strings or numbers in
your language then chances are very good
that your your strings will be sequel
strings or JavaScript strings or
something else that you can adapt from
elsewhere and the same as there's other
classes of languages like templates
where these things also where these
things are also very common and so I
think you probably came expecting
a computer science talk and I might have
just told you instead to go and copy and
paste but in fact that's a that that's
one of the real beauties I think of of
using libraries like this to get started
on a passing project you can go find an
example of how the grammar that you want
to pass is passed elsewhere and
generally with a with a few shifts
around for to match your own your own
target language get started without
really having to go back and reinvent
the wheel because I probably couldn't
sit down and just on the first shot give
you the code in the last slide without a
without at least a couple of edit and
compile cycles so just to look at one
final little bit of detailed code to see
how we're going to call the phone call
these functions source is the ice I
almost promised that the last slide was
the last slide of code but a source is a
parcel that just asserts that whatever
else we've passed is at the end of its
input because it wouldn't be it wouldn't
be a great experience if you type in 1
plus 2 ABC and you get 1 plus 2 as your
expression tree back and the ABC is
ignored we want to make sure that
whatever we've passed is going right up
to the end of the string so that's what
source does and then try pass which
superpower also provides I've kind of
expanded here to show you how we just
construct a text span over the input
pass it into that sauce parser and then
we can get an error result or a or a
value out so let's see how it behaves
that's really all there is to the
language that we've just been that we've
just been playing with so you can see
that it does work as you did earlier
it also can handle some fairly so some
fairly awkward situations like for
example if we leave an operand off the
operator then we get an error message
that makes some kind of sense you know
we expected
past that first time we expected a left
paren or something else
if we push it a bit further say you can
see things start to get a little bit
awkward like unexpected Jay is a bit
strange if you were a developer and you
were trying to interpret these error
messages then you would probably be fine
but if you're at a language that has to
be consumed by other non developer human
beings or even if you really have to
deal with it every you know every day
you don't really want to go hunting for
an unexpected five in you know a hundred
lines of of cryptic text so if you like
to properly to give you a proper
appreciation for how much work is going
to be required if you do want to add
these things to your your own projects
we'll have a look at another example
oh no that's control five and not
control f5 we have a look at another
example hopefully this one behaves
slightly differently hang on I'm sorry
let me just make sure that I'm Charlie
on the right branch
just one small detail a
thank you all right but now we're in
business you can just mentally edit out
that little glitch there 45 hours plus
nothing yeah okay and this is a little
bit better we've got something similar
but we say we've got an unexpected left
paren durational number rather than then
assign or digit 54 J gives us invalid
duration we unexpected J expected D H M
s M or s and I think that that's the
that when we're talking about these
things as invalid duration that gives a
little bit more of a clue as to what we
should be looking for and here when we
have that that final nasty example we
have an unexpected number 54 which which
if someone is trying to build an
expression to match whatever they want
to compute that is gonna make a bit more
sense to them than the unexpected five
and the tactic that this that this
example is using is called token driven
pausing now soaking driven pausing okay
okay token driven driven pausing is very
very similar to what we've just been
looking at but well our character parser
is just looking at the stream of input
one character at a time a token based
parser uses a pre-processing step to go
and find the chunks of that input that
logically belong together like the
parameters obviously still something
that stands on its own but you can see
instead of one and H being separate the
tokens that we've got in green on that
top line group up one one H and 10 M
into individual values and the tokenizer
is also the place where we can strip out
white space so that we don't need to
pepper our parser with things like token
that we were seen in the earlier
examples the other thing about tokens is
that they allow a little bit more
metadata to be added to them they're not
just a chunk of text but they're a chunk
of text with a label and in this case
we've got a left paren and a duration
and a minus and that means that when we
write the going to write the
corresponding posit there at those
the level of those elements and not
worry as much about character level
ambiguities those kinds of things but
once we do have this stream of tokens
that are all lined up sequentially then
we can just use a usual technique and
chomp them up with a parser
so let's have a look at the time
calculator and how its tokens look you
see that we've got an enum that declares
the kinds of tokens that the language
exposes we've got numbers and durations
just like we just like we did before the
token attribute adds a little bit more
declarative information that can drive
our error messages to produce the stret
the stream or list of tokens from the
input though we use the type we use a
tokenizer which can just be written by
hand you could write up a function that
worked over the input character by
character and and just yielded up tokens
as they were completed and that's that's
not a difficult process and it's also
something that regular expressions can
be used for because you're only going
from list a list you're not trying to go
from list to tree but they are tedious
to write and so super power comes with a
tokenizer builder and it will use the
same kinds of passes that we've just
looked at for howling text but use those
to match the kinds of tokens that are in
the language and so we look for A+ and
we end up emitting a plus token that has
that piece of that piece of text in it
we're working our way through the
operators we get to duration there and
that's the duration paths that we were
just building a moment ago and it's the
text parser that identifies those
alliteration expressions we can use that
as a pinch it has this funky required
two limiters argument on the end because
of this input down the bottom left-hand
side so 4 5 d6 is obviously well to me
it just looks syntactically wrong you
might your language might actually
regard that as 45 days 6 but I don't
really know what kind of language that
that what kind of concept that would
explain and so requires limiters just
says that there has to be some other
whitespace or another another token
separating those ones that are that in
fact like that
ignore spend on whites based on the
bottom is the is the way to strip out
whitespace and we'll soon see that it
can actually do a little bit more for us
than that so how do the passes that we
wrote so far change we can take number
and we get roughly the same structure
but instead of trying to initially pass
the decimal impart of them of number we
use token equal to expression token
number and then we can apply one of our
text passes to convert that actually
into a decimal value value or a double
value I should say we do that rather
than use something like double dot
powers because all the error reporting
is integrated and you remember that the
the goal of superpowers to be an end
user kind of equality error reporting
experience so because these two layers
of the pausing process are kind of
interlinked this text part like numerix
decimal double that's how we end up with
things like invalid duration and it can
point out what part of the duration is
wrong those sorts of things instead of
just blowing up the way that the
built-in dotnet type conversions would
factor is probably a better
representation of what the impact of
changing to a token driven process is
factor actually looks identical we've
changed the initial kind of search for a
left paren to being a left paren token
but otherwise the structure of this is
the same and it's the same because it
really does the same thing it could be
more it could be more confusing than
enlightening but if you imagine that you
could define your own custom Unicode
alphabet like it could be that it could
be an infinite size and in it instead of
like a and B and C you have the the
individual values that could appear as
as tokens in your language like forty
five and three days then really we're
just kind of writing a text parser over
that giant infinite unicode alphabet
it's just the same except unfortunately
we have to introduce these other kind of
concepts because there's obviously no
such thing that we can do inside a
computer but anyway that's a bit of a
digression
so the duration calculate oh sorry about
me the duration calculated that we're
looking right at right now it's based on
this tokenizer driven approach you see
that if we decide let's just run it
again actually if we decide that we want
to say one hour - ten minutes and we
maybe insert a shell style comment like
this is how long we have you see that
that's that's obviously not able to be
passed by the parts that we've got
jumping into the tokenizer though we
ignore white space we can also for
example and trivially ignore comment
shell style if we run this did I not
close it
I did not okay if we run this one our
total time you'll see that we get one
hour to do this with a character-driven
positive is not impossible but it's also
is much less pleasant to work with
especially because of the grammatical
level kind of ambiguities if we change
our mind and we want to use C style
comments then that's just as simple as
one hour plus I
really
do I not know see what's going on
I'm sure that there's Boston
yeah that's let's see you know what it
is of course it's the ambiguity that we
have to deal with where we're pausing
the slash as a division operator before
we try to ignore that text and so you
get kind of like a real live feel for
what it is like to write a parser in
this style now it's not all entirely
smooth sailing but it's also really
explicable in programming terms we're
not talking about oh that's not
compatible with the GL our parser or I
have to use lalr or I have to use you
know something else there it's really
just a piece of code that's executing
top to bottom and when we have when we
encounter bugs in parsers we can we can
use the typical techniques that we've
got for debugging
you can insert breakpoints in them I
mean this is if you've ever had to try
to deal with a positive that some that's
generated from a workbench then that's
almost a revolutionary kind of concept
have meaningful breakpoints so we'll go
one step further because I love this
little expression language and I need it
I I almost need it in my day to day life
I wish that my calendar understood it
because modulo arithmetic is just not my
thing so let's go a bit further and say
if we want to say what's the title it's
gonna be the time now plus seven days
now the now keyword obviously doesn't
exist in our language yet but if we have
a if we have a token god let's let's
keep things very very simple and direct
and we'll call the token now I could I
could type yesterday I promise and the
category of this one which is going to
drive some nice error reporting is going
to be keyword and I think that
before we get anything useful out of
that we might need to match and we match
a span equal to now and that will
produce expression token but now I'm
giving you a - I've never had t-shirts
take his spot bugs before I f5 by the
way I think probably a good strategy to
lighten up my suitcase heading back home
so now - seven hours is still going to
fare like I guess but instead of failing
right at the outset we've got a little
bit further along we've got unexpected
key word now and we're expecting either
a duration or a number
so obviously the tokenizer has picked up
that key word but unfortunately the
parson truly know what to do with it so
in the passer that I think we could
probably safely say that a token a sorry
a now a now token is going to be a
literal let's just say now and that's
going to be a public static expression
sorry
so again this father of expression token
and expression now and that's going to
just be declared if I I have to be
consistent you know I'll Drive everyone
nuts but it's got to be a property I
don't know why and that was going to be
token equal to now
and that's going to have a value of new
now expression say and now expression
obviously doesn't exist might be too
fussy about we put that type otherwise
we will be here all day I love that
Rochelle picks up that that's going to
be an expression and that's probably
enough to get us a little bit further
down the track if we put the semicolon
them that no one spotted and sorry
Kovarian this is just such a lovely
thing when you have it so now we've
gotten one step further down the path
we've ended up with the now expression
embedded in that expression tree where
we have a now node on the left and we've
got a - an operator a binary operator
and then we've got the seven-day value
on the right when we end up back down in
our expression evaluator we're failing
because we don't have an item in a
switch statement that is going to give
us that value for a now expression and
it looks very much like all the other
ones we can say you know evaluator we
have a expression no that's a now
expression now and the result is going
to be a new date time result
I'm not now I know I know everybody
thinks we should be using UTC for sure
we've got bogies coming as soon as
someone has to change the time zone time
zones are way beyond I will call that
value so that the property gets a decent
name and we went through and result also
forces us to implement to string so we
just return value to string and we do it
in ISO format because I saw 8 601 or
bust right okay how do we go now - seven
days okay so the value seven days can't
be subtracted from well that's the date
today it was same and we're in the earth
only a short note we're in the UTC plus
ten uh-huh
so you can see the bug already so that's
happening because it because in the
evaluator once we've actually matched
that binary expression we try to just
dispatch the subtraction operation and
this is the hopefully the last piece
before we will get a meaningful result
here so if the left is a date time
result I say LD and right is a duration
result Rd then we'll return a new and it
has to be a date time result and the
left value is going to be the date time
the right value is going to be a
timespan and amazingly and miraculously
done that can actually do those nice
little calculations for us and finally
yeah - seven days should make some sense
if you were in Australia right now then
seven days ago that is what the time
would be and seven days before that just
to show that you know we're really gone
all the way into the language and not
just kind of paper this on top we can
make it more interesting expression and
say that 14 days ago that was the date
so the nice thing about about Paz is
written in the style is that they are
very modular and extensible and having
features is often very much a recipe
driven kind of a process back to that
cut and paste okay so we've looked at
text phasers which have a really low I
guess barrier to understanding they're
they just work on one level but we've
looked at token passes and despite being
a little bit more complex they let us
deal with a little a little bit more
complex grammar in a simple way so
there's some pros and cons here I think
that the the main decision that you
would need to make if you were choosing
between text and token based parsing
would simply be driven by the error
message um the error messages if there's
not any other pushing requirement that's
going to drive you towards one so what
what we've learned today is that we do
all of little languages right like if we
took a survey at the door what's your
favorite technology I don't know if they
would I doubt that they would probably
be responding in the room who would name
something that didn't involve some kind
of little programming language so we
really love writing for it we love we
love working with programming languages
and domain-specific languages they are
just code and so their programs that of
course we can write so so you can you
can write programs and you can write
pauses even pretty good ones if you have
prepared to spend a bit of time digging
around in the details so thanks very
long the examples are in a repository on
github called T calc and that has a
branch for the text as a variant and a
branch for the token passive variant you
can sort of work your way through both
of those and see all of the the ugly
details that we looked at today I was
talking about superpower superpower is
of course focused on that error handling
or the error reporting case Soraka is
another positive Combinator library
for.net
which is a little bit older as this is
another attempt of mine that's ever
is earlier than superpower and it's just
a purely a text driven thing it's
probably a bit more learn about protocol
and there's vastly more examples
available for it and it shows up in
funny places like like in the credits
for eShop or I think and and lots of
other spots if performance is your thing
that are perhaps and maybe you might be
pausing something that's more akin to a
serialization format or a data language
there's something that users are going
to interactively type then one of the
developer developers at Stack Overflow
benhodgson published a library called
pigeon which is really an amazing very
very quick implementation of a text
driven past parser Combinator librarian
so if performance is like the number one
requirement on your list then you should
definitely check that out so we've got
time for a couple of questions I think
that we must be getting pretty close to
I was running out if anybody would like
to put some questions and if everybody
has a question that I'd like to put
forward now we've got some time now it's
actually almost precisely 10 minutes
which is an amazing like pute with that
little calculator there's no way we
could have landed right on this yeah
sorry over there
okay so the question was like what was
what was the difference between I guess
the tokenization part of parsing and the
and the expression parsing part you met
you mean with the rules like expression
and alt and L paren and all those things
in the factor in term yeah so if you
were tokenizing something like an if
expression then you would end up with
the tokens that correspond to things
like the if keyword and the parens
involved in it if you were and so then
the resulting power would just operate
on just operate on those if you said the
part the the tokenizer part would really
just produce those tokens and then the
parsing part would still need to build
that up into some kind of tree I'm not
under percent sure I completely
understand you but we might I might need
to we can follow up on that one after
the talk if you'd like to dig into it in
more detail yeah absolutely yeah I'm
sorry in terms of the the nodes in your
expression in your abstract syntax tree
you might end up with nodes that I like
an if expression and there would be a
condition and there would be a body yeah
building like inventing trees to
represent languages can be lots of fun
and there's also lots of different ways
to slice and dice them but I think that
that's the that's the enjoyable creative
part of the process so it's really more
than one way to have to tackle that
anybody else have anything like to put
forward okay okay so thanks very much
for coming along I really appreciate you
coming by I hope you enjoy the rest of
the conference and I'll see you all soon
[Applause]